eric notre prof de maths oui bon et
sa samba samba ça sent la rentrée vous
êtes content contraire à chaque fois il
coupe ah bah oui s'il n'y a pas de
rentrer ya pas de vacances six semaines
après alors
si pour les plus grands la rentrée est
facile les copains
chez les petits le moment est plus
compliqué à l'été passé jusqu'à ce qu'on
arrive et puis de voir tout le monde
pleurait je crois que c'est ça qui l'a
fait pleurer mais sinon elle était super
contente de rentrer et des pleurs qui se
calme rapidement une fois les activités
lancées ces vacances enfin terminer
l'es3 d'y retourner à l'école j'ai hâte
d'avoir plein de devoirs
de la musique à présent accord festival
techno qui a pris une tournure oui le
touquet musique beach festival où s'est
rendu le président accompagné de son
épouse une arrivée quelques instants
après le show d'un chanteur et musicien
franco américain marc crevier artiste
qui s'est permis vraiment quelques
minutes avant l'arrivée d'emmanuel mâcon
d'insultés de faire insulter le
président par la foule
la scène choc
et c'était bien le but de marc
reviennent la france est un pays
formidable emmanuel macron été insulté
samedi soir dans un
dans un concert que mais une insulte
inadmissible le type
on le poursuit non on le poursuit non il
est inquiété il est en garde à vue
quelque part non tu as le droit de venir
sur un plateau vous verrez la séquence
je je
je trouve ça je trouve que ce pays est
extraordinaire ça ne me ça me révulse a
prévu ce oui j'ai jeu on ne traite pas
le chef de l'état comme ça personne
d'ailleurs si on si on add on va lui
parler et justement on utilise ce sont
le fait qu'on soit une vedette une star
ou un artiste pour avoir justement un
passe droit pour à l'approché lui dire
voilà moi il faut vous disent
personnellement je ne vous aime pas
j'aime pas ce que vous faites et je vous
lis dans les yeux habitué des
provocations marc robin s est fait
connaître pendant le confinement pour
ses vidéos survoltée mais cette fois il
a dépassé les bornes estiment les
organisateurs de l'événement aujourd'hui
l'artiste de 33 ans se plaint on lui
demande de rembourser sa cachette au 5
septembre et puis on attaquera le catch
au relais qui a voulu s'acheter une
voiture qu'est ce que c'était comme
voiture en faire de puma un ford puma
j'essaie charge
qu'un chien autour de la table oui deux
ici alors je vous propose abou dhabi où
il faut trop chaud pour sortir nos
animaux de compagnie mais rien ne vaut
la clim des salles de sport et des tapis
de course pour assurer aux toutous leur
besoin d'activité physique est
essentielle ça se passe en fait vous le
voyez dans une boutique d'alimentation
spécialisés moi aussi je crois qu'il
faudrait manger des crevettes l'invité
ce soir
je suis allé voir ça
alors moi j'ai deux chats j'ai une très
vieille chatte
[Musique]
[Rires]
philippe
et moi non mais regardez cette sculpture
qu'on découvrira en détail tout à
l'heure extrêmement spectaculaire
impressionnante c'est très très beau
avec un contraste entre la musculature
très présente et la petitesse de
l'appareil génital on va dire alors ça
c'est un signe d'intelligence c'est très
bon signe sophie encore un record du
monde le but résoudre le plus vite
possible trois rubik's cube en jonglant
avec sinon c'est trop simple à ce jeu là
c'est le chinois li jian qui gagne 3
minutes 29 seulement et ça c'est pas
rien
je me suis laissé dire qu'elle avait un
talent caché oui oui
jeanne sait faire quelque chose avec son
coude qu'est ce que vous savez faire
attention musique de cirque je aller à
givet vous savez vous lécher le coude
ou donc on disait petit zizi grande
intelligence est exactement ça veut dire
que cet ordre il va pas être guidé par
des pulsions sexuelles dans la danse
anick
sa rive par des hommes qui ne soient pas
guidés par ça va en fait rare voilà moi
je hais la famille je considère même
qu'un repas de famille c'est déjà le
début de l'inceste donc
vous voulez mais votez
de second degré la famille degré non au
premier degré ça va michel tu prends un
petit peu de jeu
d'abord la famille c'est comme le
poisson jamais plus trois jours
consécutifs mais on sort tous de
vacances c'est quand même agréable de
temps en temps j'ai d'être en vacances
avec ses enfants avec sa famille entre
les parents qui souhaitent la mort
physique de la tête la totale qu'il m'a
fait demi en dehors de ma grand mère oui
mais ce n'est pas une blague